luis miró la expresión x de x x al
cuadrado más x + y al cuadrado y
escribió lo siguiente usando la
propiedad distributiva x 10 x x al
cuadrado más x yemas y al cuadrado es
igual a x x x al cuadrado más x yemas y
al cuadrado menos x x al cuadrado más xy
más y al cuadrado lo único que hizo luis
fue distribuir esta expresión de aquí
entre estos dos factores
entonces obtiene x por toda la expresión
- por toda la expresión usando la
propiedad distributiva nuevamente esto
es igual a x al cubo más x al cuadrado
porque más x x d al cuadrado menos x x
al cuadrado menos x por día al cuadrado
menos día al cubo y esto es igual a x al
cubo menos y al cubo lo único que hizo
luis ahora fue distribuir ahora está x
sobre toda esta expresión entre todos
los miembros de esta expresión
de ahí que x por x al cuadrado se x al
cubo y x por x
es igual a x al cuadrado por de x por de
al cuadrado es igual a x porte al
cuadrado y luego distribuyó este menos
en esta expresión menos x x al cuadrado
menos por x y es menos x por día al
cuadrado menos x y al cuadrado es menos
día al cubo y finalmente lo único que
hizo luis fue cancelar los términos
repetidos por ejemplo aquí tengo x al
cuadrado porque y aquí tengo menos ye
por x al cuadrado que es exactamente lo
mismo que menos x al cuadrado porque por
lo tanto esos dos términos se cancelan
también
este término se cancela con este término
de modo que sólo me queda x al cubo
menos d al cubo conjeturó que x menos
por x al cuadrado más x yemas de al
cuadrado es igual a x al cubo menos d al
cubo para toda equis y todas y uso louis
razonamiento inductivo explica tu
respuesta en este caso luís no uso
razonamiento inductivo lo que hizo fue
construir una prueba de hecho está mal
que diga conjeturó que porque una
conjetura es algo que tiene evidencia de
que es cierto pero no tienes una prueba
formal de que es cierto por lo tanto
aquí la palabra conjeturó es tan mal
empleada lo que hizo luis fue
precisamente construir una prueba por lo
tanto aquí louis le vio haber dicho he
probado
he probado
x de bla bla bla bien entonces uso luís
razonamiento inductivo no
él hizo una prueba
hizo
prueba una demostración
ok usar razonamiento inductivo quiere
decir encontrar un patrón en las cosas y
tratar de generalizar lo por ejemplo si
luis hubiera usado razonamiento
inductivo hubiera dicho algo de la forma
bueno si pongo x igual a 5 y igual a 7
entonces 5
7 por 5 al cuadrado más 5 por 7 más 7 al
cuadrado es igual a 5 al cubo menos 7 al
cubo y quizás lo haya aprobado para 12 1
y 7 y 32 y 24 entonces para todos esos
esta fórmula era cierta
por lo tanto si hubiera hecho eso si
hubiera usado razonamiento inductivo
pero esto no es razonamiento inductivo
esto es una prueba formal lo que hizo
luis se vale para todas las equis y
todas las porque sólo está usando la
propiedad distributiva y lógica
elemental sumas y restas entonces lo que
hizo se vale para todos los números por
lo tanto es una prueba formal y no es
razonamiento inductivo